you've got this guy built up with his
team of people or the team of people who
was working with and they have cracked
this code and why do they need computers
where did Colossus commit colossus came
in because the sheer amount of counting
that you had to do was enormous he were
basically in the end looking for the
occurrences of dots or zeros in well 41
times 31 times five times whatever you
know you might also afford to get the
whole research section doing just one
little bit of it but day in day out all
you wanted to do was to look for
patterns and count out the number of
zeros within them and you need a
computer it doesn't matter it's a
special-purpose computer which Colossus
was when they first realize this they
tried to go back to enigma type
technology oh we understand about relays
and uni selectors let's build something
electromechanical it was called his
Robinson and for those of you in North
America Heath Robinson is the direct
equivalent of Rube Goldberg
they were both cartoonists that drew
impossibly complicated electromechanical
machines and make cartoons out of them
so there's this huge amount of stuff to
be counted up but electro mechanically
when they tried to do it it couldn't go
fast enough it would take days and they
tried to speed the machines up and they
just went up in blue smoke and
eventually I think Alan Turing had
worked with Tommy flowers from Dulles
Hill GPO general post office he'd worked
with them for some aspects of the Enigma
decode but as we know enigma
electromechanical was just about okay
but Turing said winder why not let's get
in flowers for an opinion and Max Newman
who was by then head of resistors and
bring me will have a chat and flowers
took one look at it and said you will
never get it fast enough to do what you
want electromechanical II forget it
we've got to go electronic and use valve
and of course there's a huge flower its
are you off your head we all know valves
I go back
every few minutes they're not reliable I
think I've said this before I'll say it
again Tommy said to them I've been doing
research on use of thermionic valves in
telephone exchanges and I can tell you
they can be remarkably reliable so long
as you never turn them off and it's
particularly the heaters on the cathodes
if you bring those up to voltage very
quickly so they instantly go red or
white hot the filament will go back but
if you bring them up very carefully some
dull red to bright red and all that and
then at the end of the day don't switch
them all off lower the voltage and do
that very very carefully you will
minimize the number of thermionic valve
blowouts you get and so basically the
message was never ever turn them off and
it'll be fine and in the end it was and
the electronic speeds were just about
enough but it's still talk a typical run
on Colossus to discover initial settings
on a pair of wheels might take 10
minutes something like that and you've
got to do that for five different pairs
so you know you're taking about an hour
to work out settings if you didn't know
them already standing oldest said you
must never take more than two hours if
you haven't got it sorted by then on the
settings give up go to another message
but then if you knew the settings but
didn't know the wheel patterns that was
a huge amount of effort was needed in
fact Frank Carter reckons 10 hours of
Colossus time to establish what the
patterns of ones and zeroes were on the
wheels now you've realized why they
ended up with 10 colossi Bletchley Park
they got a huge amount of work to do
and he mustn't also run away the idea
that Colossus could do absolutely
everything he couldn't the great
majority it could but it relied on this
slight statistical disparity though
almost more zeroes than ones and look
for that what setting makes that happen
but just occasionally a rogue message
would come in where it just happened to
be
fifty/fifty and there wasn't a skew or a
bias and then you have to throw that
what do I say we'll come back to that
later so it wasn't 100% but it was good
enough to make a decisive difference to
the war yes he seems a weird doesn't it
that it's not 5050 between zeros and
ones in a in a regime where we're doing
exclusive ORS well what you've got to
remember is if you exclusive or
something with itself you get a bunch of
zeroes but whatever it is you exclusive
all those together if they're identical
the exclusive or on a character basis
will be five zeros and to make those
show up at Bletchley they denoted it
with a forward slash if you remember
okay well that's all very well but that
so how would that lead to a bias a scoot
and sir hmm in many many languages not
the least German and not the least
English which as we must remember is a
Germanic language you get doubled
letters ok so Sean if I say to you I'm
guessing the probability of Z in English
is 1/100 what's the probability of
getting two Zed's 1/100 times 1/100 well
that would be the mathematical ones yeah
yeah if they're all independent it will
be one in 10,000 but they're not doubles
red is far more common in even in
English less alone in German than one in
10,000 really you know dazzl puzzle all
these kind of things it's not massively
common as a bigram
but it's more common than the base
probabilities would indicate double peas
as well happy slapping flappy all these
kind of things so character doubling was
one of the vital components of saying
that if you look on a certain stream and
it's a zero and you look on the adjacent
streams from 2 to 5 and it's a zero as
well then it's an old character and that
could have been generated by having one
thing exclusive Ord with it's identical
thing so on a bitstream basis they
adapted that and said the reason we are
seeing
more zeroes is that if you slide these
bitstreams over each other by one base
and exclusive-or them you'll find that
double letters occurrences lead
eventually to more zeros coming out than
ones because on the nature of exclusive
or if something is the same as something
else and you exclusive for it it gives
zeros not ones so it's a bit rough and
ready and hand wavy there's more to it
than that but that is just one example
of how the language structure itself can
do you in and it's reported that the
German Crypt analysts realized that this
would be a weakness of the Lorenz cipher
but they said we're not to worry it
would need you to build a machine and
I'll never be able to do that there'd be
so much data it will kill him
you'd need roomfuls of people and even
within a month they wouldn't do it but
what they didn't foresee was the advent
of machines with electronic speeds not
just electromechanical ones and that
could just about get on top of it
will the manipulating bits era become
obsolete in a few years or basics will
never change I think basics will always
be there in some sense we will always
have to worry about how much memory we
have how much processor time we have we
was being all informal is that hi Dave